nowadays it's getting rarer and rarer
that a new anime becomes a so-called
hidden gem
everything is being watched everything
is being reviewed even with a huge
amount of anime getting released all the
amazing shows bubble up in history
remembers here are the actual good shows
and the other ones that didn't quite
meet the hype but this season we're
living in some bizarro world where
freaking everything is good
so you've got several shows i'm
absolutely gobsmacked more people aren't
watching but it's simply because people
are watching other great shows that
simply had more initial hype
behind them but i mean i've been doing
anime youtube for like over 10 years now
and i feel like some of these shows just
need a little bit more of a push to get
the recognition they deserve
because it's such an easy sell like for
example i can say are you watching vv
and you're like no
and then i say why not it's like a cross
between violet evergarden the terminator
and near automata written by the same
guy who did re-zero well then you're
like okay but so then i show you this
and then you're like alright then guess
i'm watching vivi but sometimes you come
across a show that's harder to sell
something you can't just show a cool
scene or summarize in one clickbaity
tagline but you know that if you just
convince someone to give it a chance
they're gonna think it [ __ ] slaps and
that's basically odd taxi or taxi is one
of those series where you watch one
episode and you're like hey this seems
pretty cool i might give this a watch
but let me see what else is on offer
first
holy [ __ ]
hey what was this about again because
that's exactly what happened to me
but thankfully being a good old nihon
resident the series was inescapable if
you ever rode a taxi in the last six
months in tokyo because hey guys it's a
series called odd taxi about a taxi
driver in tokyo
so let's put it on the back of every
taxi in tokyo ever
genius actually you know what that was
[ __ ] genius because it reminded me to
watch it
and if i didn't i would have missed one
of the most engrossing anime on offer
this year
paired with some of the best writing
i've seen in a while welcome to the
underbelly of tokyo the backdrop for a
class of colorful characters that
seemingly have nothing to do with each
other
an enthusiastic college student looking
for any way to get viral a desperate
bachelor who would do anything to get a
date a tired nurse with a secret of her
own
a sleazy gangster looking to please his
boss there's an idol group and their
biggest fan a stand-up comedy duo
corrupt cop and somewhere in the middle
of all this there's a mysterious girl
who's just gone missing somewhere in the
city but
what's all this got to do with anything
what initially seems like a group of
unrelated characters on their own
journey slowly starts to interconnect
as the mystery is unravelled their paths
start to intertwine with each other and
right at the center of all this there's
one single taxi driver who's
run out of [ __ ] to give it can be hard
to tell what the hook of this show is
meant to be
or what the show is even about at the
beginning because you are introduced to
so many different things
that seemingly have nothing to do with
each other but it's one of those shows
where if you have the patience to stick
around you'll be rewarded as the puzzle
pieces start fitting together and the
dot starts getting connected nothing is
there for show
everything has a purpose for those who
pay attention you might even be able to
make sense of it all before it's fully
revealed
this is a mature mystery thriller that's
often been compared to tarantino movies
and
honestly i absolutely agree not just
with the format of presenting a grand
narrative with a bunch of interconnected
characters but just the feel of the
whole thing
there's just something about the
dialogue in tarantino movies that is so
addicting
you hear these characters talk and it
just doesn't sound like your typical
movie dialogue it feels so natural yet
it's not exactly realistic
either you know as much as i would like
to think i can have tarantino-esque
dialogue with the boys on the saturday
night at the pub it's almost as if you
get a snapshot of the optimized version
of naturally occurring dialogue you
recognize the conversations but there's
a certain rhythm to it people are on the
top of their game everyone says exactly
the right thing at the perfect time to
say it
it's like conversational poetry and odd
taxi captures this energy
perfectly it's witty it's snappy it's
human conversation in peak form and
sometimes it'll throw a curveball at you
like you could have two characters
having this deep
intimate conversation this guy is
telling this girl to stay away from him
it's unsafe he has dangerous people
after him he's involved in something
bigger than himself and for her own good
she shouldn't be involved with him
and in response to that this happens
[Music]
what everything about the show exudes
this energy of an indie anime i mean
it's not
it's by pony cannon but it just somehow
feels so vastly different from your
usual
otaku bait seasonal anime pulp fiction
no khan chief old men
taxi driver before thinking of other
anime this is comparable to
these are the things that come to mind
when i think of what odd taxi is like
so what is it about the writing that
makes this show stand out
you may have heard the term chekhov's
gun the concept where no element in the
story that is presented to the viewer
should be unnecessary in the words of
anton chekhov himself if you say in the
first chapter there's a rifle hanging on
the wall in the second or third chapter
it absolutely must go off
if it's not going to be fired it
shouldn't be hanging there
i [ __ ] knew it of course this doesn't
always have to refer to a literal gun
but any object or element that is
introduced
should lead to an eventual payoff i'm
sure you've all watched or read a story
where a big plot element was set up and
introduced that didn't actually lead
anywhere or mean anything at the end and
you're just left there thinking
so wait what the [ __ ] was the point of
bran being able to possess animals again
the reason i bring this up is because
unfortunately odd taxi doesn't have a
chekhov's gun
that's right he has a [ __ ] check off
arsenal this [ __ ] probably breaks the
chekhov geneva convention is getting
tried at the checkoff um for check off
war crimes hold on a second i've just
finished watching our taxi and i'm on my
way back my check off apache helicopter
it's a rare sight when you see a script
where seemingly every
single little bit of detail has a
purpose as a writer it can be easy to
forget about small aspects or just look
over certain elements but
odd taxi manages to juggle so many
characters so many different story lines
intertwining them into this chaotic mess
that somehow becomes coherent when the
end is in sight
the script is so tight it can fix your
leaks better than flex seal
one thing leads to another which affects
something else which connects everything
together
tick after talk after tick after talk
the ebb and flow of the series is like
watching a ruby goldberg machine in
motion
every episode you're given a new puzzle
piece no scene unnecessary no
single piece of dialogue wasted but for
every new breadcrumb you are given the
whole picture slowly but surely becomes
more visible
plot lines intertwine characters crash
into each other tension builds up until
eventually
everything is revealed
it's absolutely incredible how much care
and attention has gone into the writing
here
there could be a scene where characters
could be having this seemingly random
conversation about the meta of tinder
profiles and you don't realize until a
few episodes later that a piece of
information was exchanged that gave a
clue to what was really going on
or a single shot somehow foreshadowed
what was about to come
it's like the writer has a chronic fear
of loose ends because no stone is left
unturned or detailed left unchecked and
here i am watching this being like [ __ ]
i can't even keep track of where i put
my phone like five minutes ago and
[ __ ]
all right this this isn't actually part
of the script but i literally can't find
my phone right now but in between the
grander plot you have these really
personal grounded stories surrounding
the various casts that can hit
a little bit too uncomfortably close to
home sometimes
a lot of these characters just seems
like dudes you've known struggling with
some kind of insecurity and because of
that
you want to root for them even through
their worst decisions there's a dude
who's just obsessed with trying to get
popular online
and um i don't know can't really relate
to that there's this dude who's taking
out loans to make it seem like he's as
rich as he said he was in his tinder
profile and i'm like
come on man can't you just be like a
normal sane
person and subscribe to and only fans
like everyone else
but for me the standout one is the one
depicted in episode 4 because
this may be the single best stand-alone
episode of this spring anime season
at first you're like what kind of
episode is this we're focusing on a
character we've never seen before with
no
previous connection to the plot and
we've gone from a missing person's
mystery case to a guy playing gacha
games
what the hell is going on but as this
guy tells his story
you start to get absorbed from a simple
boy who just wants to be accepted by his
friends who just wants to feel like one
of the cool kids for once
to an overly competitive obsession of
collecting erasers
one mistake leads to another one domino
follows another domino follows another
domino follows another
every part of his life feels like he was
fueled by the mistakes of his previous
actions you see the journey of a
perfectly sane man spiral down into the
darkest depths of gotcha addiction
because
well this is his fate this is what his
life had led to
this is what he was meant to do and as
this all plays out his
place in the story starts to make sense
the dots start connecting and when
everything's said and done
you have a man who's completely snapped
because he couldn't get some bird in a
gacha game
i mean wow what a psycho right couldn't
be me imagine losing your mind over a
[ __ ] dodo like
what i mean come on it doesn't even have
a swimsuit edition it's rare to find
storytelling as engrossing as this and
for god's sakes it's about a guy playing
a [ __ ] gacha game but this episode
perfectly captures what makes this such
a standout show
i feel like there's something else big i
forgot to mention about this show
oh yeah they're animals did you notice
look i know what your first thought was
when you saw these designs because it
was my first thought as well
oh hey another show to add anime's furry
phase we're apparently going through now
you know it was cool when b stars came
out but if i have to sell another show
with the tagline it's like zootopia
but i might just have to put on a
fursuit myself and [ __ ]
woo myself to death but honestly i don't
think it's actually anything like that
because the fact that they're animals
plays such a small part of the show
in fact it hardly plays any part of the
show a lot of these series blends human
behavior with animal characteristics but
here their animal size are hardly
ever referred to at all to the point
where a lot of people have thought that
this was just a live-action drama in
disguise
so why the [ __ ] can't we just see that
version i want to get married i want to
have babies
before i'm like 26 years health
insurance actually you know what let's
just keep it out of me odd taxi is an
absolute master class in writing that i
know
a lot of people have looked over and
with that having just come recently to
an end it's been a while since i've seen
a series
this complete with a mystery series as
plot heavy as this
anime's had a bad reversal of kind of
dropping the ball when it came to the
ending or just leaving us with something
unsatisfactory with everything it built
up
odd taxi however didn't just stick its
landing it [ __ ] did a triple double
backflip twist with one hand type
on his back landed on two feet and
casually got gold in the olympics in the
process
it's been so long since i've seen an
anime with a story that was just the
full package from start to finish
many series have struggled and failed
trying to juggle less than what's going
on here but
by the final episode the series not only
managed to weave everything into one
coherent narrative made sure every
chekhov gun was fired in spectacular
fashion
tied up all its loose ends but it also
somehow did it all seamlessly
it doesn't have the flashy visuals or
the big names behind it or the
pre-existing fan base to hype it up but
what it does have
is just pure engrossing storytelling
i know it's a busy season i know there
are much more high-profile titles out
there i know these animal character
designs aren't the most appealing things
in the world but
i do sincerely hope that more people
check this out this had an uphill battle
from the start to get noticed and i
think a series like this was always
going to be classified as that
underwatch underappreciated hidden gem
but you know what maybe we can change
that
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoy the video let me
just
sorry god damn this is a good opening
thank you very
much to levados manopla pony star
dysfunctional degenerate alpha sigma
jeff and everyone else my patreon for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible
look guys i know june was a bit of a
quiet month for me but i was actually
really busy
but i was actually really busy but i
actually had a really really busy
schedule
off this channel doing stuff for other
channels so
that's why you didn't get many videos
that month but also i've been working on
some super big videos as well which you
can expect
this month so this is going to be a much
busier month than last month so we're
starting this month with an odd taxi
video i really hope you enjoyed it
because
more [ __ ] people need to watch it i
know this isn't going to be the most
viewed video on my channel
but my god i hope those of you who did
actually watch this video you end up
giving it a shot because it really does
deserve it but yeah you can expect a
much more regular upload schedule this
month
and beyond so yeah i'll just leave it at
that for today because
i have no further updates so everyone i
hope you have a wonderful day
i've been giggling and i'll see you all
next time